I'm Rachel Zuraw. I'm live here in San Francisco. I'm an attorney
specializing in, intellectual property. Especially pharmaceutical
and biotechnology. With a background in bioethics.
>> Great. Well, we're very happy you're here. we have just learned a little
bit about Henrietta Lacks And what we learned in the story of Henrietta Lacks
is her non consensual contribution to science.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And over the years, how her
cells were used for many great medical advances.
And her family has ultimately, really hasn't
been compensated in any way, financially. But has
recently, there have been a couple of
things that have happened where the NIH has
put family members on a committee to help
them decide how the genome of HeLa cells
is going to be used, who gets the information.
>> Very recently.
>> Yeah, very, very recently. What I wanted to
talk to you first about was really Just. Actually, You
know? What are the ethical issues surrounding the use
of specifically, Hela cells, in the case of Henrietta's story?
>> Mm-hm.
>> But also the, the issue of using tissues from people,
without their consent, in general.
>> Well, that's a big question, you
know, what are the ethical issues with this,
because it has to be couched in a way in a long history of failing
to see consent from people who involuntarily
participated in medical research, like Henrietta Lacks. it's
one of the fascinating things that Henrietta
Lacks story and HeLa cells is the ability
to identify An individual who participated
in research without her consent. Most of
the time, these sort of looking back at people who accidentally moved research
forward inadvertently, not voluntarily. That's groups
of people who were in many ways
taken advantage of by the medical establishment.
The researchers who took the cells from
Henrietta, as you've already covered, you
know, they were attempting. There were multiple
attempts to find this immortal cell line, and they were taking samples from
anyone they could. She was there for therapeutic treatment when they took the
cell line, and at the time the, the cells were harvested from Henrietta Lacks,
there were not, the informed consent guidelines weren't in place,
requiring. Well, how in-depth should I get to informed consent?
>> well give it a try. I'll stop you.
>> Okay. So, the Nuremberg Trials of the Nazi
physicians who participated in medical experiments. Well, quasi medical
experiments in the concentration camps. The, one
of the first principles to come out of
the Nuremberg trials is that the voluntary consent
of a human research subject is absolutely essential.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And that's been embroidered on in
United States law and ethical guidelines ever since,
the informed consent. That any individual participating
in research needs to be told beforehand They
need to have all of the information that they are able to
understand, so that they can agree or not, to participate in the research.
>> So, it must be fully voluntary.
>> It must be fully voluntary, fully informed,
and fully voluntary. You can't make a voluntary
choice to participate, if you don't have all
of the information. Now you mentioned the Nuremberg trials.
>> Yes.
>> Which happened I believe in the 1940s.
>> but the Henrietta Lack story
happened I think in 1951.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So was there anything extra compounding the issue with Henrietta Lack
that maybe hadn't caught up yet with informed consent in the United States?
>>
[LAUGH].
informed consent in the United States in the early 1950s was still a, a
good theory, y'know, everyone thought that this sounded like a great idea,
but then you have an uneducated patient
in the hospital, who doesn't understand what treatment she's receiving. Is not
advocating for herself. And in the consect of
the time, in the context of the time,
most physicians would not have paused to think,
I should explain to her why I'm taking
this tissue sample and let her know what I'm
going to do with it. Today, and we can
discuss some other examples, that sort of behavior still
goes on, but it's recognized by the medical establishment.
>> Mm hm.
>> To be an actual intrusion and invasion of
the patient's autonomy. Of the human research subject's autonomy.
>> Now, for people who are hearing about this story for the first
time. it may be important for us to sort of briefly discuss the
idea that, You know? To use the phrase, maybe she was a victim
of the, sort of. contemporary climate and culture that she was in, may
or may not be true. I mean, I guess what I want to
have you speak to is, there was
nothing specifically malicious done against Henrietta Lacks.
>> Nothing.
>> It's more along the idea that there was a right
that we recognize now, that was violated at that time. that
happened.
>> Exactly. Now that's one of the trickiest things about the Henrietta Lacks
story, I agree, is that at the time when the Hela cell line was first harvested,
there was no recognized duty to tell a patient that you had taken some
of their genetic or cellular material for
research. The researcher who took the material wasn't
even intending to profit off of it. He may have had, he may have felt,
he probably would not have realistically felt
any obligation to tell her if he intended
to market and profit off of the Hela cell line, which he did not. But
his intentions were pure in his mind.
He was trying to advance the scientific cause.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And there was no recognized obligation to
the participants in the study to inform them of
their participation.
>> Right. Now, obviously things have chanced since then, and,
>> Incrementally.
[LAUGH]
>> Okay, incrementally, then.
>> Leaps and bounds maybe not as much as we would have liked.
[LAUGH]
>>
Well, I want you to speak to that for a second, then.
I mean, did the Henrietta Lack story Change anything? If not at
the time eventually? And if not that were there other cases that,
you know, had a bigger impact on we will get informed concent?
>> Well the Henrietta Lag stories, you know, it wasn't known for more than
40 years. So, when the Immortal Life
of Henrietta Lacks was released, when Rebecca Skloot
sort of publicizing the story then I think the story has now become part of
a really interesting movement towards control over personal genetic information.
Which I think we're really just seeing the beginnings of, because
legally, there was never a recognized right of
ownership or control of your, well in the past,
tissues, blood sample, etc before genetic information
could be extracted and used from those samples.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But now, you know Henrietta Lacks. You mentioned that
her descendents Are now sitting on a committee to authorize
the use of the genetic information link from the Hela
cells. Likewise, there was a really interesting decision in 2010,
regarding a small Indian tribe that lives in
the Grand Canyon. Who had given blood samples
to a University of Arizona researcher, for it
to be used in diabetes and schizophrenia research.
one of the members of the tribe found
out several years after these blood samples were
donated, that they were being used for purposes
that the tribe members had not consented to.
>> Mm-hm.
>> The University
of Arizona, of course, argued that this was perfectly acceptable,
they had the samples, they had no right of ownership
to the samples. However, the ultimate outcome of this case is
that the trail was able to dictate that they
would not authorize their blood samples to be used for anything other than the
original intended purpose and actually all of
the samples that they donated were destroyed.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So I mean these are just a couple of isolated examples, case by
case situations, not really setting the precedent
for how we're going to be managing,
>> Mm-hm.
>> Genetic information that are, that is in the hands of
researchers, but, it's indicative of
the interesting movement towards people becoming
aware of and taking measures to control the use of their genetic information.
>> Now, in that same thing, I feel like I've heard, and maybe you'll correct
me if, if I'm wrong, If you know, Is it true that, if I
had discarded a piece of my tissue or of myself. If I have left skin
cells behind. If I have left bits of me, you know, a hair follicle with
the root attached somewhere and someone finds it, are they free to use
that sample however they see fit, if it's been discarded from my body?
>> At this time there'd be nothing to stop them, no.
>> Is that a hotly debated issue?
>> Discarded genetic tissue, it's being debated. I
wouldn't call it one of the biggest issues in
bioethics at the moment, but it's certainly out there
and I think it's going to become more and
more of an issue as, well I mean it's a two-fold thing, right? As
both science advances such that we can do more with a discarded hair follicle.
And as individuals in society, non-scientists become
aware of what can be done with
a discarded hair follicle, then I think
you're going to see a lot more legislation
[LAUGH]
aimed at
>> Sure
>> Aimed at preventing those uses. I mean, we're going to talk about GINA.
[UNKNOWN]
genetic nondiscrimination act, which, that was sparked
back in 1995, before there was a very real possibility of workplaces or insurers
discriminating against people based on what could be uncovered in their
genome. But science was getting there and people started to worry.
>> Yeah, sure, I mean, it often, it seems that we rarely
get ahead of the curve on these things. But, that's one of those things where
they were. I want to ask one more question, more about the Henrietta Lacks
story. You know, there are people who claim that she sorry, I should say there
are people who claim that, that the,
the Lacks family, Henrietta Lacks family, her descendents.
Henrietta Lacks is deceased.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But that her family deserves some sort of the financial benefit, that has
occurred from the use of her cells, and not so much morally speaking but
legally speaking. When a tissue or a sample from an individual has been taken
in a way that we consider unethically or illegally today, maybe not at the time,
what are the ideas surrounding financial compensation, in
that sense? I mean, is there any validity
to those kinds of arguments? Or is that
just more of people arguing from a moral standpoint?
>> That is a moral standpoint. The commercial
rights to your tissue, once it has been
separated from your body. Are, for better or
worse, pretty much zilch. one of the first cases
on the area was the Regency of the
United States of California versus Moore decades ago.
But in that particular case More, the patient
was going down to UCLA for treatment of
[UNKNOWN]
cell leukemia. Yeah.
>> Mm-hm.
>> His physicians said that they needed to remove his spleen for
therapeutic treatments. they actually intended without disclosing it to him
to isolate material from his spleen and from his blood sample
to create a highly profitable cell line. And for years actually,
they kept him coming down. He lived in, don't remember if it was Washington.
>> Mh-hm.
>> I think. they kept him coming down for visits that they said were
therapeutic for the treatment of his leukemia.
But they were actually harvesting samples for
use in developing a cell line that I think was valued at about $3 million. Once
he found out, he sued trying to you know, get a share
of this, not irrationally one would think.
but the courts ruled that he had the, the doctors of course, violated
some rather important duties of disclosure. Towards him, that they
should have, like the guidelines of the American Medical Association, their
ethical guidelines require that physicians disclose
if they have any commercial interest.
>> Mm-hm.
>>
[LAUGH]
you said they, physicians violated some duties of care in that vein, of not
disclosing their commercial interest in his materials.
But that he had no right to
any of the profits, derived from his,
cellular material. And there's actually a line
of cases on that same principal. And
this is actually, a really interesting debate
in intellectual property and in bioethics about
whether, whether giving
individuals any kind of commercial right to their bodily materials, and the
products derived therefrom. A lot of opponents of doing that say that it would
have a drastic chilling effect on research, that if,
you know, physician researchers were always going to be beholden to the
individuals who hopefully knowingly donated their material to the research.
>> Mm-hm. Then the physician researchers wouldn't bother to
do the research in the first place to explore
commercial possibilities. I don't know whether or not that's
true. I'd like to believe a little more in altruism
than perhaps that debate
[LAUGH]
presupposes.
>> Sure.
>> But. Fantasy world, who knows.
>> Right.
>> Anyway, that, it's just a really interesting
debate going back and forth, about whether or
not to allow this kind of commercial interest.
And also, whether to allow, whether to allow control.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Over the use of tissues, and now over genetic material. There have
been a number of fights about whether or not, for example, a physician
who has collected a number of tissue samples while at one university can
take those tissue samples with him to his next university. And you know what
studies can this be used for and do you legally need a,
legally, you probably don't need a consent of the donors. Ethically,
Fun question.
>> Yeah, that is a fun question. Well, so, that, that
sort of brings us to, to a new point, then. I mean,
we, we, we've changed in the last 5800 years. We do
have these new rules of, at least informed consent. Voluntary informed consent.
>> Mm hm.
>> And there seems to be a new worry, as you mentioned a second
ago. In 1995 there was a, a big concern about the power of personal
genetics, and what it would be used for.
Why are people so worried about genetic discrimination?
What is the biggest worry in people normally site
and say, this is scary, we need to do something
about this. This is a moral imparity. What is, what is behind that?
>> Aside from the movie Gatika,
which I think is behind a lot of it. It's a very scary movie.
>> It is.
>> I don't know if you've seen it lately. GINA was conceived
of in the past because people, people are very concerned that opportunities will
be forestalled based on a possibility of some genetic issue that could befall
them later on in life. If that they are being, you know, pre-judged,
pre-penalized, based on something that might not happen.
>> It seems very, like, antithetical to the
western philosophical idea of individualism and free will.
>> Exactly. I mean, it's. Alright, you can understand, you know, from
a gut level why of course it's terrifying to think like, you know,
why are you, why won't you hire me, why are you charging
me all of this extra money to get health insurance just because someone
in my family had a health problem that
will probably never effect me? No, it seems unfair.
>> Unfair.
>> which is, you know, a very high-minded, ethical and legal concept.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> What so, GINA, or the Genetic Information Nondiscrimination
Act, was passed in 1995, and what did it do?
>> GINA was actually signed into law in 2008. It was a very long
process. So, it, the fight to create GINA first began
in 1995, you know, a bunch of the bills that eventually became
GINA started circulating through the government back in 95, and
probably being talked of even earlier. I'm so sorry, you're,
>> No, I was going to ask what did what did GINA
do? What did it say, what was the legal meaning behind it?
>> Well, GINA's general goal is to prevent discrimination by
employers with 15 or more employees, or by insurers, based on an individual's
genetic information or family medical history.
So they included family medical history in
part because, y'know, not everyone has had their genome sequenced. But the idea
is, there are a lot of, this breaks down into a lot of different
provisions, of course, a lot of different
individual, granual protections. That the, an insurer
cannot raise premiums based on the fact that, say, my aunt had breast cancer. I
may or may not carry one of the BRCA gene variants that would increase my
likely risk of receiving breast cancer. I cannot be charged under GINA a higher
premium for that. Likewise, your insurer or your employer cannot require that
you undergo any type of genetic testing to assess your risk for developing any
condition. Your, it permits of course in health, a health care provider to
recommend genetic testing for various purposes. But
even then, an insurer or an employer
can only collect the bare minimum of information that
they need to have for coverage decisions. Basically they
cannot collect and store additional information regarding your genetic
Make up predispositions, whatever we're going to call it.
>> Are there ways around that?
>> How do you mean?
>> I'm just wondering you know so legally I can't raise your premium because
you have the BRCA1 mutation,
>> Mm hm.
>> But could I raise your premium for some other reason? I mean, do, are there
any examples? Workarounds where people do end up discriminating based on these
based on personal genetic information, anyhow? Or is it just, is
it not even something people really even try or think about doing?
>> So far, it really hasn't been an issue. and I think it's. I
think one of the reasons is because, a lot of the early thought in,
you know, some of the predecessor builds to GINA was, okay. Sure, you can't
make someone take a genetic test and
discriminate against them on that basis, but you
can take down their family medical history, and discriminate against them
on that basis. Which, of course, you know, principles of genetic inheritance.
so that's why that got folded into GINA in the first place. I'm not aware of any
successful work arounds actually that anyone has tried
yet. Perhaps that's because it's an iron clad law.
>>
[LAUGH].
Such a great piece of legislation.
>> Or more likely the challenges haven't made it into the courts yet.
>>
[LAUGH]
I could go with either of those. Do
you feel that concern about genetic discrimination is valid?
>> Absolutely. I mean,
you can all to easily imagine an employer, you know, saying,
you know, let's, let's not say breast cancer, let's say someone who has a
you know, they've had their genome. they've had their genome coded and they
show a likelihood, it shows, you know,
that they will almost certainly develop Huntington's,
>> Mm-hm.
>> Say, and an employer who wants to make a
long term investment in an employee if they have access
to that information, they're allowed to make decisions based on
it. Might say, you know, we really rather have some
who'll have a longer working life with us, likewise in insurer. I need insurance
Make their money based on having the maximum number of
basically healthy people paying into the insurance pool which then.
>> Right.
>> Goes to pay for the less healthy people. it is in the
insurer's best interest to keep as many people who are going to develop
serious conditions out of that pool as possible. So yeah, I think
that's a completely rational concern that people have that led to GINA.
I think it's one of the few occasions when, as you said,
they got out ahead of the
possibility of experiencing this type of discrimination.
>> You know we discussed BRCA1-1 mutations, we talked about the biology
behind it and we even mention the idea that. And Myriad was
a company that patented the human gene sequences, the mutations,
that cause, that are the BRCA1-2 mutation. And these patents have allowed
them to develop a diagnostic acid that no one else can touch that
are the three dominant BRCA1-2 mutations. And they
have fought vociferously in the courts to
keep those patents.
>> It was a long and bloody battle.
>> What what is the current state of gene patenting in the United States?
>> So the current state of gene patenting, thanks to the decision on
June 2013, I think it was June 13th, 2013. On the myriad case,
is that human genetic code is not patentable.
However, code that is synthesized from, like
if you, I cannot say, I patent that mutation you have, because I discovered it!
However, if you synthesize that DNA, a thing that's called CDNA
>> Mm-hm.
>> That is patentable, because that is a product of human innovation.
So a lot of the debate over the myriad case and the patenting of genes. Has
really been about the purpose of patents in the United States. And you
know this whole history of intellectual property
protection in the United States. Which is super
fun stuff that probably doesn't need to be done in depth in a Genetics Course.
but the purpose of patent code is to
protect the fruits of, human innovation. Either if you
have worked on something. And you have created something.
You are entitled to control it and profit off
of that. For, you know, protected period of
time. Which has changed of course, throughout patent protection
history. Which you're entitled to exclusively profit off of
that for a period of time as a reward
for your labor in bringing this new
thing into the world. So patenting of natural
materials has actually been, there's a pretty
extensive case law that this was not something
that you could do. Because you can't just, you know, discover a mold, scoop it
out and say, I patent this, I get to use this mold alone. A lot
of people were arguing that genes, the discovery of genetic
mutation, took so much effort and took so much ingenuity to isolate. And
to interpret this information, that that made it patentable.
And, there actually you know, Myriads patents were not the first to be issued.
>> Mhmm.
>> Myriad was really just
the worst behaved patenter
[LAUGH]
a of human genetic information.
>> They didn't make any friends.
>> Exactly.
>> Even since the Supreme Court decision, it
seems that they're still going after people. I know
that there are companies that, you know, were
trying to run with the Supreme Court decision and.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Myriad is still suing them.
>> Yes. Yeah, there, there's plenty of clean-up work left to be done.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> But yeah, over the course of this
litigation, people were arguing. Instead of invalidating patents
like this then having this sort of compulsory
licensing system was another idea that's you know, common
to further scientific innovation by licensing your patent.
Licensing your discovery. And the whole problem with myriad's
holding of all these patents that led to
all these lawsuits is they didn't grant any licenses.
Which was putting a choke hold on research. And of course an individuals ability
to access a diagnostic test to determine
whether or not they had these mutations.
>> Now, what about other genes, so, I mean, obviously
we can't patent human genes, can we patent cat genes,
can we patent tree genes, can we patent bacteria genes?
Unless they are synthesized, and therefore a product of human innovation,
they're not patentable.
>> Now what I find fascinating, and I don't even
know if you're aware of this or not, but CDNA.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And our students don't know about this yet, we haven't talked about it in
the course, but CDNA is a type of DNA Created when take an MRNA, which is
when we have a gene in our cell, and it's turned on, it's transcribed into an
MRNA. We have enzymes that can we can, in a lab, add to that mix and
turn that MRNA back into DNA. And the interesting thing
about MRNA is it's spliced together. It originally starts out really
long, but we cut a lot of pieces of the MRNA
out, and the resulting MRNA is really short, and it just
has the genetic information that gets turned into the protein.
So when you turn an MRNA back into CDNA, you only
get the relevant coding information that was used, but a gene
is actually much bigger. A gene itself has tons of information,
called entrons, that don't end up in the final
product. But there are genes that don't have entrons, that
are just entron-less. So the MRNA is pretty much
the same length as the gene itself. And I'm really
curious to know what the supreme court thinks of
that, because technically the information within a CDNA of an
entron-less gene is the exact same as the gene
itself. So I just wonder how you know if it
really is about the nature of the, of the molecule, or if it has to do
more with the information in the molecule. Like
is it, is it the idea that it's synthesized?
>> Hm-mm.
>> Or is it the idea that the
particular order of the information is not natural?
>> That is a really, I mean I think that will be an interesting question when
it inevitably turns up in court. Because the idea at this point is
that you can patent something that is synthesized. I don't know what to tell you
that if the product that you synthesized
is informationally completely identical to the natural product.
I mean, the. Although, then, the CDNA that you're working on
would still be something that you've produced in the lab. The CDNA.
>> Absolutely.
>> That is, you know, being circulated to other labs to
do their research on. That is a lab product. As opposed
to, you know, I took a sample from Matt, and I
worked on that because it's informationally identical to the cDNA. So.
>> Hmm. I'll
be interested, yeah, I mean.
>> I'll be interested to see how that, how that shakes out.
>> Yeah.
>> But at this time, the distinction really is
in the Have you synthesized it? Have you altered
this from its natural state? And it's not really
about information altering, although it's
usually about purifying and distilling.
>>
Alright so we're going to transition.
So we're going to speak more about, sort of, your
job and, or the idea of bio-ethics in, in general
>> Mm-hm.
>> How important do you think it is for us to better understand genetic
information, but also the nexus of genetic and ethics together for
our future? Do you think this is going to be a more pressing
need? Do you think we've already figured out most of the hardest stuff?
[LAUGH]
And hard stuff behind us? where do you see the
place of bioethics in the future of genetics and personalized medicine?
>> I actually think that bioethics and especially
a knowledge of genetics is increasingly important, because, you
know, bio-ethics, as a concept, originated as an
idea of how to protect participants in research, and
consumers of healthcare. People who don't have all
of the training, and the information held by
the physicians and the researchers, who are, you
know, bossing them around. Standing there in white
coats looking scary and saying, give me your
blood, I'm going to go do great things with
it. It's important in order to, protect autonomy
that people have, as we've talked about, informed
consent. You need to have the information going into
a study. But I don't think protecting informed consent is
just about giving someone a form when they're coming into
a study and saying, this is exactly what we're going to
do, this is what you're going to experience, do you sign
on the dotted line? Okay. It's about making sure that
people have the tools to understand their participation in such
an area, in such a venture in the first place.
And that's by insuring that people are educated
about, genetics, about personalized medicine. About, the that
possibilities their future and their genetic code actually
hold. What that actually means for them. The
level of predeterminism, or not. That this information
actually implies. And, well, I'm perhaps a little
bit biased in favor of the study of
bioethics, because I think it is super fun and
interesting and really important. But, you know science is advancing at
a pretty breakneck pace, and you know we won't always get out in front
of it like with GINA, but. Someone needs to be
paying attention and, you know you never want to say stand
in the way of any kind of scientific advancement. I don't think that's at all
what the study of the intersection of ethics and science is about.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But, ensuring beneficial and responsible use, I think,
is critical to respecting the people who make research possible.
>> I want to know, how did you get interested in
bioethics? What's your background? What did you study in school?
>> So my background, I came to
bioethics as a philosophy major, as an undergraduate.
I, I began studying human rationality,
mostly. And philosophical conceptions of understanding
individuals as rational beings. And what your ethical duties to a rational being
are. That led me into studying informed consent and medical ethics. ' because I
found it fascinating. I mean especially how you get informed consent.
How you get any kind of consent from someone who
isn't rational, was formerly rational, was never rational. Fun questions.
>> Yeah, seriously.
>> and then that in tern lead me actually
to becoming a lawyer. Because I realized that, law is
the tool that you're actually going to use to make sure that people that
cannot advocate for themselves, are none the less protected. So.
>> So, understanding genetics, for you then,
is Or at least the certain fundamental
principles of genetics is sort of central
to understanding what the very questions are.
>> Exactly. my knowledge of genetics. I took some courses on
genetics as an undergraduate, and you know, sort tried to keep
up since then. Has been important toward understanding
what's going on in the world towards isolating my own research questions
and to my everyday practice as a lawyer which, you know, I don't tangle
in bioethics everyday. I don't tangle in genetics everyday. But my
background with, you know, studying science and
the implications of scientific discovery has landed
me working in intellectual property and technology in
my law firmware. I need to be ready to learn and understand a new scientific
or technological concept based on whatever case
is thrown at me that particular moment, and.
You know the tools of knowing genetics has
helped me in a couple of cases definitely.
[LAUGH]
>> That's good to hear. so let's say there's
somebody watching this interview and they're super excited. They really
like the idea of bioethics. They like genetics. And
they're interested in maybe in law and they just want to
know what they could do. What advice would you
give to a budding young bioethicist? What would you tell
them to study? Or what would you tell them
to do or where would you tell them to work?
>> A budding young bioethicist. Well,
I'd tell them to read philosophy. Because again,
exposing my own bias. where to work? I mean,
there're a lot of essentially, even when I
started studying bioethics, there weren't a lot of jobs
for a bio-ethicist. Now you see jobs for
bio-ethicists at pharmaceutical companies. You know who want to
know both how to do their research and how
to distribute their product. How to market their product.
hospitals. Definitely need people. There are they need bioethics
consultants, actually, who mediate between physicians and patients
to help, help explain the information and the implications
of it. Genetic counselors are, you know, field, I don't know if you've
discussed in this class, but that's what, where a lot of bioethicists wind
up is, translating this kind of, you know, probabilistic
determinism. You know, translating that to people who don't
have the educational background always to understand it. And
help them make their decisions based on that information.
>> Mm-hm. So, you know, best advice I can give to learning bioethics is just
be open to figuring out what the next weird issue is going to be and learn all
you can about it.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> That's why bioethics is fun, right? It's sort of a, a
mix between hard-nosed practicality and science
fiction. You're paying attention to, what could
go wrong? And how do we stop that? Or, you know? Aspirational
fiction. What, what's not great right now? How can we make it better?
>> Great. Rachel, thank you so much for comin' in.
>> Thanks for bringin' me in.